from blocking highways to forming human
chains and dressing up as characters
from Margaret Edwards dystopian novel
The handmaid's Tale
for three months up to half a million
Israelis have taken to the streets
across the country to protest a Judicial
overhaul planned by prime minister
Benjamin netanyahu's government the
growing Revolt piled pressure on
Netanyahu to suspend the overhaul until
Parliament reconvenes at the end of
April
leaderboard
here's what's happening in Israel the
stakes behind Antonia's judicial
overhaul and where things can be headed
next
there are many layers to it but there
are three things you need to understand
first is changing the committee that
appoints judges this overhaul will give
the ruling Coalition a majority on that
committee and that will allow them to
place like-minded judges on the bench
the second pillar of the judicial
overhaul is to limit the jurisdiction of
the court that means what cases will the
court be able to hear and the third
thing and perhaps the most controversial
bit is What's called the override Clause
that will allow a simple majority of
parliament meaning 61 of 120 lawmakers
to override decisions of the Supreme
Court Netanyahu and his Coalition
Partners say this judicial overhaul is
necessary in order to balance out the
court they say that the court is
dominated by liberals and that it's way
too activists the court itself needs to
check on its power because it is
essentially blocking the will of the
people for people who oppose the
overhaul they believe it will undermine
the Supreme Court completely we came
here to protest against the
Israeli democracy we see a process where
the rights of the people will be
overtime consumed by this Theocratic
government these protests have really
exposed long-held divisions in Israeli
Society between its secular side and its
religious more conservative side
one of the major problems of this
overhaul for the protesters is that it's
being Advanced by prime minister
Netanyahu himself Netanyahu has long
been a defender of the court and they
ask themselves why is Netanyahu
certainly supporting this massive
judicial overhaul and for them the
answer is clear it's because Benjamin
Netanyahu is on trial for corruption and
if this overhaul passes they believe he
will use it in order to get out of his
own legal problems Netanyahu denies this
but the protesters at this point simply
do not believe him
has paused legislation it will be very
very difficult for the opposition and
World coalition to find an agreement on
this issue because they are so far apart
as it stands perhaps the opposition and
the Coalition will find the compromise
but if they don't we can expect this
conflict to come back and to come back
stronger
[Music]